ANGELA VON DER LIPPE:
Thank you, Amy.
A preliminary disclosure,
I work for the last
of the independent
publishers, WW Norton,
whose name I think
you'd agree is
synonymous with interests
of the university,
but it wasn't always so.
As I discovered last week
when my husband handed me
an article from
the January 28th,
1924 edition of the
Harvard Crimson.
With the headline,
"Lecture halls
may become the laboratories
for lecture publishers."
With the alarmist subheadings,
"A cultural correspondence
school, " and, "Aristocracy
of brains threatened,"
Sound familiar with all the
talk about cognitive elites?
It was a piece from the founding
of the People's Publishing
institute based on
a series of public
lectures at Cooper Union and the
new school, sponsored by one,
William Warder Norton,
an upstart publisher
making it his business
to make the university's
business available to the
public through books no less.
I had no idea I worked for
such a subversive publisher.
In any case I think that the lab
experiment, for the most part,
worked out in everyone's favor.
So let me turn to the
challenges we face today.
When I sat down to
write this talk,
the first thing
that came to mind
was, well, I'll have to
tell them it's a crap shoot.
And then came the backpedaling,
no, I can't tell them
that, that's not what
they need to hear.
Still whatever else I tell
you today, keep in mind
the one certainty about
trade publishing--
it is a crap shoot.
That same afternoon I was
in my car listening to NPR
and I tuned into a conversation
with the biographer, Bob
Richardson, about his
latest collection of essays.
And he was talking about
the cash value of an idea.
And the term was
jarring, and I winced
as I realized that it was none
other than William James who
coined the term, his low
lectures on pragmatism,
public ones for which
he got a pretty penny
and probably had kids in school.
But as dissonant is the
phrase, cash value of an idea,
seemed to me, it wasn't
just the commodifying part
of it felt a little vulgar.
It was maybe that
the question, what
is the cash value of an idea,
struck a little too close
to home.
To something we
people in publishing,
and all gradations of
publishing, but especially
the trade grapple
with every day.
And however much I tell
myself that the cash
value of an idea isn't
its intrinsic value,
or its whole value,
isn't what I do,
I'm stuck in an
industry like so many,
that looks to the market
to determine value,
and indeed, will make
their publishing choices
based, in part and
sometimes in large part,
on a cold calculation.
So I'm not infrequently
torn between two publishing
responsibilities--
the one captured
in the German word for
publisher [GERMAN],
transferring goods and
money, and the other
in its Latin root, [LATIN].
Getting the word
out-- much more suited
to my impractical nature.
My job is to be a first
reader, to help authors craft
their words and
arguments in a way that
captures the public
imagination for their subject,
reaches out to readers,
delivers the goods.
But I'm also a bookmaker,
dealing in ideas.
And that's what anyone
publishing serious nonfiction
these days is doing.
I'm collecting and making
bets on idea books.
And this is what I want
to briefly address today.
How we all can approach writing
for the trade with an eye
toward beating the
odds of the market.
Let's face it, it's an
industry in tremendous flux
with a few years ago, some
50,000 books published
each year in the US alone.
And that's before you factor
in the exponential increases
in titles through
electronic sales,
and all the other noise
in the marketplace.
As a publisher, it's
a formidable challenge
to get the attention
of the marketplace
out there for your idea book,
your serious nonfiction,
or for that matter, your
book of literary fiction
when it has to compete against
a sea of other books, celebrity
books, sports books, comic
books, murder and mayhem,
redemption, rumor, conspiracy,
especially today when
it is often delivered on the
same device that streams music,
film, and endless games.
Case in point, 30 years
ago Cosmos, the book,
and Cosmos, the TV series
occupied different galaxies.
Today's new Cosmos
will be available
in dual formats and mixed
media instantaneously
on the same device.
So you can bet when
it comes to a choice
to be seen interactively,
or read singularly
which format will prevail.
The book may have to work
harder today to be read.
One of my authors, the
cosmologist, Sir Martin Rees,
has written an eloquent
little book entitled,
From Here To Infinity.
It's based on his Reith
lectures he delivered last year.
And in this book, he
passionately enlist scientists
of every stripe, pure and
applied, to come out of the lab
and in from the field to assert
themselves as global citizens.
"Scientists have a
civic responsibility,"
he says, 'to inform
the public of what
they do, their process, their
discoveries, their methods.
Why?
Because never have the
stakes been as high,
the misinformation
been as saturated,
and the power and fate of
the many been as concentrated
in the hands of a
disinterested few,
valuing political expediency
over scientific truth."
I was reminded of Rees'
appeal to scientists
when I read the opening
pages of Marketplace of Ideas
about the role of the university
in today's global world.
And what resonated
with me from that book
was a basic appeal
to the university
and its members also, to
get out of themselves, out
of business as usual, and think
of novel ways of doing its core
business, generating ideas
that shape the culture
and are the binding elements of
our social fabric, our memory,
and our vision.
And what better vehicle
for clarifying those ideas
and forging that
critical connection
with the world
than the book, even
in the turbulent world of
technological innovation.
And that's just to say,
with so much out there
to distract that public
from critical thinking,
what we do in publishing
serious nonfiction, in what you
do in writing it
expressly for the trade,
may have more of a critical
function today than ever.
So what do we do to
get their attention?
When we editors consider
projects that proposal stage,
and for that matter
later, promoting it
to critics in the
greater world, we're
frequently asked what
the take away of a book
is, what readers will
draw from the argument.
It's an eye-opening exercise.
It can be ridiculously
reductive,
but it's also useful.
And you may be listening
to these remarks saying,
what's the takeaway?
I have to confess, I rarely
publish a prescriptive book,
hate being told what to
do, and I'm the last person
to give you seven simple
keys for the academic,
writing of a
successful trade book.
But I can't give
you a few pointers.
A few things to consider
in framing your projects
for the trade.
I think I know where
you're coming from,
as I came from
academic publishing,
right down the street at
Harvard University Press,
and before that
I'm from academia,
and easily 2/3 of my
authors come from academia.
And while I can't deny that
academic writing is often
code for deadly, dispassionate,
obfuscating prose
because it can be
just that, it's
also true that
academic writing can
convey something very special.
And that's authority,
nuance, and originality.
It's avoiding the
former and capitalizing
on the latter that will make the
difference in writing a trade
book.
Ideally, you want to capture
the public imagination
for your subject by delivering
a fresh perspective,
a new argument, a scientific
horizon, or a story never heard
before in prose that enlightens
and doesn't speak down
to people.
Tall order.
Journalists, for
the most part, rise
to this challenge with ease
because they are constantly
distilling complex
ideas in brief compass
and pitching their
work to the media.
But academics have a
difficult time calibrating
what they know, and the
requirements of scholarship,
against the needs of a
good persuasive story.
Here are just a few things
to consider in thinking
about writing for the trade.
, One synthesis.
One of the reasons that people
like Carl Zimmer and Malcolm
Gladwell and Fareed Zakaria as
such successful trade writers
is that they are
natural synthesizers.
Academics who are
naturally invested
in a specific corner
of research find
it painful to take a
wide angle approach
to writing for the trade.
When Brian Greene's proposal for
a trade book on string theory
came to trade publishers with
the title, Hidden Dimensions,
and the promise of
an immediate dive
into a mire of
multiple dimensions,
the book was rejected by the
trade, except for yours truly.
And that was probably because
I was fresh from Harvard
University Press.
And it was on its way to
be published by Princeton.
There are worse fates.
In the end, the
approach was altered
to a historical
unfolding of space time
through relativity
and quantum physics,
culminating in multi-dimensional
space of strings,
with the title, The
Elegant Universe.
It caught on.
It wasn't driven
by his research,
he wasn't the central
figure in the string worl--
Ed Witten would have been.
And given its subject matter, it
certainly wasn't an easy book,
but it was one
that readers could
scale by virtue of
the angle of approach
that Greene had so
deftly provided.
Synthesis drives some of the
most successful trade books
by academics, as
I'm sure you know.
Steve Pinker's first trade
book, The Language Instinct,
drawing on Chomsky,
and Dan Goldman's,
Emotional Intelligence, on the
work on social intelligence,
and Howard Gardner's,
Multiple Intelligences,
approaching their subjects
with a wide angle vision.
There is often a lag of many
years between the emergence
of the research in the
academy and its distillation
in the trade.
It's not that there's nothing
new under the trade sun,
but that trade books take
a while to percolate,
and are perhaps a better measure
of how ideas and research
resonate in the culture.
The second point is passion.
Writing for the trade also
gives you a unique opportunity
to express your passion for your
subject in ways that. academic
writing may frown upon.
So it's a chance to
write outside the box.
And it's amazing how
a consistent dose
of personal feeling can hold
the attention of readers.
How you accomplish this, which
narrative devices you employ,
will depend on your story.
Astronomer Chris
Impey, in a book
yet to be published,
How It Began,
may invent a time machine to
take us through lookback time
to the first three seconds.
Eric Kandel in his book,
In Search of Memory,
intersperses personal
biography with the grand story
of the revolution in our
understanding of memory
from the theory of
psychoanalysis, the talking
cure, to cells talking to
each other in neuroscience.
It worked for Kandel
actually, because Kandel once
aspired to finding
the id, the ego,
and the superego in the brain.
He wanted to be a psychoanalyst,
he started that way.
That melding of
biography with narrative
will not work for everyone.
And Nietzsche was
right when he warned,
authors need to shut up when
the work begins to speak.
But you have to find
your own way of bringing
your passion to your narrative.
All part of what
Ursula Le Guin notes
about writing as, ultimately
a connection with the reader.
That you write a story and
the reader completes it.
Well truly, if that happens,
that is passion in action.
The third point is people.
One way to infuse your
narrative with passion
is to pepper it with people,
historical or real life
doesn't matter.
I'm amazed at how many really
very interesting proposals
I receive from academics
that are really
heavy on interpretive
analysis, and can
be curiously devoid of people.
They have names, but no people.
Ideas need to be embodied.
Arguments need to be dramatized.
And discoveries need to be
felt, as well as explained
and defended.
With Brian Greene,
for instance, there
was no way a trade
book would sustain
the math necessary to convey
the work of string theory.
So, as we talked about it,
he told stories at that point
in the narrative.
What was it like to make
a collective discovery
or breakthrough
in string theory.
It wasn't graveyard duty at the
Smithsonian, so what was it?
He told his story.
It was very effective.
There's no more compelling
way to present an argument
than to embody it in
people and context.
The fourth and last
point is audience.
Who are you writing for?
I should have begun with this
because if you get that right,
other things will start
falling into place.
If you're writing expressly
for your colleagues,
then it truly is not
at all in your interest
to push a book out
into the trade.
It will be lost or ignored and
won't give the book its due.
Journals are there
for the short form
and university
presses are far better
equipped to get the word out
in book form to professionals.
To reach the trade
reader, you have
to think of your
audience as intelligent,
lay readers for whom
you are opening up
a subject for
discussion requiring
no assumed knowledge-- so, your
colleague in other departments.
Finally, I want
to say a few words
to the state of trade
publishing-- the trade
publishing industry which has
been on death's door for 30
years now.
There are tremendous changes
that are taking place,
and we don't know what will
shake out for publishers.
I heard somewhere publishers
today described as scribes
before Gutenberg.
And I said, because I don't
want to believe that, no, no.
Gutenberg changed literacy,
created a symbolic world,
this isn't that.
Last October I was in
Germany, but didn't
go to the Frankfurt Book Fair.
I went on a personal
vigil instead,
to Gottingen to visit
the literary archive
for the first time,
of a woman I'd
written two books on-- a
novel, and a work of nonfiction
on Lou Andreas Salome.
And when I arrived,
I actually sat
in a small room with her books
by Rilke, Nietzsche, and Freud,
and they were
crumbling in my hands.
And on the way
back to Frankfurt,
I was left thinking about
the afterlife of words
held in the palms of a
book for so many centuries.
And later that evening,
I asked my husband,
returning from the fair, if
there were any books there.
And happily there were still.
A couple of years ago the NBA
award winner, Patti Smith,
and one of Betsy's clients,
made a moving appeal
to not completely abandon
the physical book.
And what I drew from this was
that raw, sensual connection
to ideas that only books afford.
And I found it heartening
that this year the NBA
award for nonfiction
was awarded to a book
about rescuing a manuscript
from 1,000 years of oblivion.
A book of dangerous ideas,
Lucretius, On The Nature
Of Things.
If you have not
read this, read it
it's quite and
extraordinary book.
Copying and translating
it, and changing
the course of civilization.
The book about the book was, of
course, Stephen Greenblatt's,
The Swerve.
I take that as an altogether
good sign for books,
and especially for
books of ideas, the ones
you need to write and
we need to publish.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]